- You look beautiful.
- Aw, thank you so much!
- I love this dress.
It's like y'all called each
other with your colors.
- I kind of just said that.
- Yeah, kind of just like --
- Oh, actually all of us.
- Yeah. Wow, we should form a group.
Um, so, well congrats.
It's your first baby, right?
- First baby, yeah. Thank you!
- [Kelly] Congratulations!
How are you feeling?
I was really sick.
- I, actually, you
know, feel great so far.
- Knock on that wood girl okay. Okay.
- Um, the first trimester was interesting
because I was filming in a corset.
- Oh. Oh God.
- And I was always nauseous,
but I think because I had
the distraction of the movie,
I could just kind of keep
going, but I just literally,
I don't know what you ate
on your first trimester,
but I just ate bread
and rice and potatoes.
- I barfed and then was like hospitalized.
And then I gained like 80
pounds. Like it was like,
it was the worst experience ever .
- [Frida] Yeah, no, I actually,
I actually had not too bad,
but yesterday was my first heartburn day.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I'm in my third trimester now.
- Yes.
- Does it get worse?
- You know, we'll just move on.
(laughing)